25 years guys little birth anniversary
jeepers what did you get a gift for 25
years no no see you need to tell CBC
funding campaign the good news is that
with all the hurricanes and fires and
earthquakes incoming nuclear war we
might be the generation who gets to know
how the world ends there's a brilliant
format to start off with it keeps moving
well I remember when on my first year on
the show yeah which was this year and
you know you always I always loved that
idea of just going after things that are
happening in the media and kinda cuz
that's the real sense of truth that's
the real sense of communication we get
to say things that other people can't so
that's the real beauty of it I think
yeah it's week to week 2 which is
exciting that's what that's why this
show should last another 25 easily
what's great about a format like this is
not only as things to Wan do we added a
new cast in our cast changes but the
cast of characters we made fun of
changes I mean when we started when I
started or Kathy started the show you
might have correction you know choking a
guy and you think oh my gosh choking a
protestor can't get any crazier than
this and then Rob for happens and Justin
Trudeau can't keep your shirt off and
Donald Trump's gonna blow us all up it
gets crazier and crazier so it's hard
sometimes actually to catch up because
the world that we live in now is much
crazier than the world we would you be
interested in visiting the Canada's
national igloo absolutely yeah we used
to have to tone up the news now we have
to tone it down just to get to funny
you can just pluck it verbatim from the
news which we embrace when we think
about Oh Trump and what's going on in
the States whether your former against
me doesn't matter there's all this media
blasting out there about the end of the
world is nigh climate change is gonna
destroy the world like everything is so
heavy it's like no no come hang out with
us will point that out but we'll show it
through a lens that is you know we're
bringing some levity to that kind of
heaviness and I think it's important
that we do that that's our job and also
if it affects political change I think
that's also a part of our job it's not
just about making people laugh and feel
light we also have to be a commentary on
what's going on in the world right now
so hey Kim Jong you're the racket man
you really are do you like taking on
this character well what a first started
like I thought okay well this will be
fun during the election you know we'll
have a bit of fun and I'll do Trump and
and and then he won and then you've
realized it's kind of like when your
mother says don't make that face the
wittle change it'll stay like it so now
I find my name my face has changed like
it's 2-minute so he didn't expect you
but it can't be but the thing is with
Trump you think okay surely to God
that's enough people have seen enough
you're sick of it we should move on and
then he'll be like I'm gonna totally
blow up North Korea you're like okay put
the wig back on you know he keeps
amplifying it and trumping himself which
is amazing to see and then it can also
be very fun to do on the show the weird
thing about Trump when he was
campaigning though when we did the first
couple of sketches here we did him in
front of the crowd and use the crowd as
a background as a rally as I just said
to him like okay as I give the speech
just kind of cheer me on and the more
you'd be saying we're gonna go we're
gonna build a wall and people too
we're gonna do this we're gonna get that
guy want to get him out of here people
yeah calm down you realize how mob
mentality really work